to defeat your opponent you must become
your opponent what's your wow rabbit
and we are back live getting ready for this final
match up maurice ashley he can still hear me but
he is nervous so i just want to point that out
to everybody that maurice hey man you sweating
a little bit definitely i you know i have to
move quickly a one minute i don't know given how
quickly he's played as well how well i've seen
him play so far i just hope i have enough time
because his resistance is going to be the whole
thing how quickly i can somehow get an advantage
all right and just you seem you know pretty
optimistic right now rizzo what say you man
what do you think about this match of 10 minutes
for your boy against one from maurice well this
is this is for me the rematch of the century you
know like a few years ago some years ago maurice
came to the studio and put a weapon on me jezza uh
masterchella and it was five minutes to one minute
and none of us was able to get a victory on
him um but since then you know it's been a
lot of games judges as you can see his game
is extremely improved and now he has double
the odds so this should be real exciting and
real interesting i'm really interested to see
what comes out of this and i gotta honestly
say jesus is looking for revenge today guys
so let's see what happens it's gonna be two
games too right uh i believe so let's get
confirmation of that and you know how are you
guys you guys feeling ready for your your game
yes i'm good let's make it happen let's get
the show on the road let's do it let's go
uh so we're about to see giza have 10 minutes
till maurice is one maurice you better have
those wrists stretched you know those fingers
ready it's not easy playing with one minute
thank you robert oh and we do have the
game underway maurice has the white pieces
and he just dropped his bishop out
and look at jesus playing bishop e6
putting pressure on c4 rizzo what do
you think about the opening so far
light and fast i mean this is this is kung fu
at his best and maurice has to he needs to move
as quickly as possible but he's kind of quiet
i thought he's gonna be trash talking maurice
where's your head i ain't trying talking this
guy right now man i got to get my game going
oh and jesus is super quiet because
we're all focused is what it is
look at this guy he's not making any mistakes
yet james what do you think about the early
going here um maurice keeping a great pace
honestly great pace here but jizza got time
and he fighting i mean this is not clear
like nobody's getting crushed or nothing
this is going to be a uh a fight as you
see look at that bishop retweet b5 queen c2
i'm not liking him playing this well man i'm
not winning yet he playing it well isn't he
he really is he's not normally this
quiet when you're playing chess right
he is super focused right now
he has all brain muscles moving
um and uh he's he's responding fast he this is
the fastest he was he responded all day in fact
well maurice did just snag upon so i can
sense that maurice feeling a little bit better
about his chances but he only has 33 seconds
and giza continues to move at
a pretty lightning pace himself
queens came off so we got into the end game how is
uh how is jizz's end gamer is how does he do here
i think his end game is good he he he's always
you know you know he understands hanging
pawn principles he understands isolated pawn
principle that's actually one of my weaknesses
so let's see how high uh okay i would say
part of the issue is when somebody has
27 seconds left the game should be as complicated
as possible but right now honestly jesus putting
up some really stubborn defense james it's only
a one pawn deficit you think he has it in him to
hold this off uh yes actually well now too okay
well and maybe one let's see what he does let's
see but i think he can hold it here he's actually
fighting this is uh very very tough for him to
face this and i think jesus is taking the the
the the time advantage he's using he uses a lot
he's utilizing his time in advance he knows that
oh my gosh i just blundered i saw you wandered
i saw maurice's face he was not happy
i blundered did you see the draw a lot
oh i saw it but i wasn't gonna say anything
because i didn't want to give any hints we'll
definitely show that out for the game but wow what
tenacious defense though i mean look at this game
7.2 seconds so he's gonna have to pre-move some
moves here but looks like he's getting that queen
we got it here it comes oh my gosh i
pre-moved did you see that blender that
would have been a terrible pre-move that was
awful maurice your face is awesome when you
premiere you get like all scared did you
see that yeah oh now i gotta win this game
you gotta go you got three seconds oh but you
can i you got this man just pre-move it out
oh that was also a bad
pre-move ah all right it was
if you went the other way with your king
here like towards the end when you were king
on the 63rd movie with king c1 yeah you
want king e1 because maurice had pre-moved
he would put his queen on g2 and
that would have been a stalemate
wow that was exciting guys great game just
maurice kung fu sword plays impeccable
that was uh that was remarkable right there but
just got a chance to revenge here right you get
more shot at it he does he gets one more chance
hey did you learn anything from that first game
like what are you going to change about your
strategy what happened yeah maurice slashley
i hate to give advice in the middle of a match
given that i you know but since i won the first
game already i'm going to give you a little bit of
advice you're playing badly on the time you're not
handling your clock time properly you got two
minutes and 27 seconds only that you use on the
clock right maybe next time you should slow it
down and try to you know think about your moves
so you don't make the same mistakes you played
well but you're playing too fast although to
also give jesus some credit here you only have
1.6 seconds left the end of that game yeah
yeah but i was winning like i was still
winning so so the the point is if he had
slowed down there was a moment in the game we
could talk about it again afterwards like there
are couple of moments in this game if he had
slowed down he would have found the right moves
yeah i thought about that afterwards it seemed
like i was playing like i only had 10 seconds left
exactly i want you to do that so you know be
careful because you gotta i want to show you
not a lot i'm thinking we both had a minute for
some reason i snapped into that mode exactly